la valeur de lier à conversational se
mesure à la capacité du logiciel à
comprendre le langage et à mener des
conversations l'apprentissage
automatique qui sous tend ces
conversations étape les modèles de
langage il fait appel à des techniques
telles que l'apprentissage non supervisé
une approche l'apprentissage automatique
qui vise à examiner des tâches telles
que le langage et pas seulement des
points de données bon je n'ai pas écrit
ça mais en tout cas quelles sont les
explications fournies par un algorithme
appelé gpt 2 lorsque je lui ai demandé
ce que sont les modèles de langage bon
techniquement et répété d'eux m'a fourni
une réponse en anglais et j'ai ensuite
utiliser un autre algorithme appelé deep
end pour permettre la traduction en
français et je pense qu'on peut dire que
au final le résultat est vraiment pas
mal
peut-être même surhumain à bien des
égards ou du moins la réponse de gpt 2
et sont meilleurs que ce que 99% des
humains répondrait si on leur demandait
ce qu'était les modèles de langage et
encore j'ai pété 2 est un algorithme de
début 2019 il a donc maintenant deux ans
autant dire que dans la lignée des
algorithmes de machine learning
c'est déjà devenu plus un dinosaure son
évolution gp t3 est capable de prouesses
plus surprenante encore et les
équivalents de google sont sans doute
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
impressionnant encore mais comment
est-ce possible comment ces algorithmes
ont-ils atteint de telles performances
parfois peut-être même souvent
supérieures à ce que 99% des humains
répondrai aujourd'hui on va voir que la
prouesse de ses algorithmes moderne
réside en fait dans la têt raisonnable
efficacité du paysagisme pragmatique
en effet ce que ces modèles de langage
essaie de faire c'est déterminer la
probabilité d'un mot sachant les mots
qui l'entourent par exemple dans la
phrase la valeur de l'ia conversational
se mesure à la capacité du logiciel a le
langage et à mener des conversations
quel est le mot probable dans l'espace
laissé vide quelle est la probabilité
que ce mot soir par les quais les
apprêter qu'il soit modéliser calé à
profiter qu'ils soient comprendre en
particulier pour écrire du texte les
algorithmes de langage vont typiquement
chercher à deviner le mot suivant
probable sachant les mots précédent
comme c'est le cas dans les algorithmes
d'auto complétion de vos téléphones
ainsi pour la phrase il fait appel à des
techniques telles que l'apprentissage
non supervisé une quel est le mot
suivante le plus probable tel est une
question typique que les algorithmes de
traitement de langage se pose à longueur
de journée et alors si vous avez suivi
cette série vous avez certainement
remarqué que le problème de complétion
de phrase est en fait très similaire à
celui de l'induction introduit par david
pugh et à celui de la prédiction définie
par un seul run off où les beats sont
remplacés par des mots en fait le pur
bail à nice mme de solomonoff s'applique
parfaitement aux problèmes de la
complétion de langage et donc à la
génération de textes crédible bon alors
je mens comme on l'a vu se base à nice
mon regard des calculs déraisonnable ce
qui rend le pur belize à nice mme
inapplicable en pratique cependant les
chercheurs en informatique n'ont pas
baissé les bras plutôt que d'appliquer
la formule de belize
ils ont défini toute une machinerie
complexe à base de transformer de
mécanismes d'attention et de descentes
de gradient pour effectuer des
approximations rapide à calculer de la
formule de pays qui de plus sont
parallèles is able sur des unités de
calcul comme des cartes graphiques ou
dit autrement les chercheurs machine
learning ont développé des algorithmes
très sophistiqué de paysannes isme
pragmatique et de façon spectaculaire
ce mécanisme pragmatique a réussi des
prouesses ahurissante comme la faculté
de décrire leur propre fonctionnement
mais comment est-ce possible
sinon d'une équation aussi simple que la
formule deux pays permettent d'acquérir
des facultés conversationnel aussi
impressionnante
les lois des probabilités sont elles
vraiment suffisante pour apprendre une
machine à parler comme un humain voire
mieux que 99% des humains l'équation
utilisé pour résoudre l'énigme des deux
enfants peut-elle vraiment permettre de
comprendre le langage non la principale
raison pour laquelle le belize à nice
mme pragmatique peut nous paraître
déraisonnablement efficace et sans doute
lié à notre incapacité à envisager les
conséquences de ce bel et à nice mme
pragmatique appliquer un très très très
grand nombre de données façon de plus
générale les certainement critique de
noter que lorsque vous apprenez les
probabilités
vous appliquez généralement ces
probabilités a très très peu de données
publiques non dans cette série les
calculs explicite de la formule de bayes
basse et l énigme et et aux enfants où
le problème de mon petit rôle des
problèmes avec extrêmement peu de
données ces petits exemples ont le don
de nous familiariser avec des lois comme
la formule de baines
cependant ces exemples font aussi
extrêmement trompeurs puisqu'il se
restreignent constamment à des
applications des probabilités à petite
échelle mais le belize à nice mme qu'il
faut appliquer c'est le bail à nice mme
appliquée à l'ensemble de toutes les
données que vous avez collecté dans
toute votre vie comme on l'a vu dans un
épisode précédent
ceci correspond à au moins des milliers
de milliards de données il aurait ainsi
fallu appliquer la formule de baise des
milliers de milliards de fois pour
savoir ce que le bail à nice mme nous
pousse vraiment à croire et en
particulier si vous voulez juger le
basis mme à partir de ces résultats
c'est ce calcul qui aura fallu faire
c'est notamment en vertu de ce
classement cumulatif du savoir que
l'idée de suspendre son jugement
et de conclure uniquement en fonction du
résultat d'un test significatif est en
fait extrêmement fallacieuses
il omet complètement le préjugé qui
résulterait en fait de l'analyse de
milliers de milliards de données passé
déjà collectés même si ces données
n'offrent souvent pas qu'une réponse
univoque aux problèmes sous
considération ils offrent généralement
des informations partielles en fait
critique pour affiner notre jugement
en fait ces informations massive du
passé sont même souvent plus informative
que les résultats du test statistique
celui ci ayant ses propres limites
malheureusement appliquer la formule de
base une seule fois et déjà horriblement
complexe surtout si on considère un
nombre combiné à tauriac de théories
concurrentes appliquer la formule de
base
lle de milliards de fois ça dépasse
complètement notre imagination
et c'est précisément pour cela qu'on a
tendance à gravement sous-estimé la
déraisonnable efficacité du paysagisme
même lorsqu'on se restreint à dubai à
nice mme pragmatique un bon baïse à nice
mme pragmatique doit tenir compte de
l'ensemble des milliers de milliards de
données auxquelles on a eu accès faute
d'efforts pour ne serait-ce qu imaginer
les conséquences d'un tel calcul
monstrueux on est voué à être surpris
par les conséquences du bail léninisme
voilà une chose que le génialissime alan
turing avait anticipé dès 1950 dans son
merveilleux article il écrivait ainsi la
chose suivante je cite les machines me
prennent très souvent par surprise
c'est en grande partie parce que je ne
fais pas suffisamment de calcul pour
décider de ce qu'il faut attendre d'elle
ou plutôt parce que bien que je fasse un
calcul je le fais de manière précipitée
bâclée et en prenant des risques et ça
c'est alan turing trop souvent
malheureusement beaucoup de pseudo
bayésiens à commencer par moi même au
lieu d'effectuer le calcul parisien nous
faisons un calcul de manière précipitée
bâclée et en prenant des risques voire
beaucoup d'entre nous ne faisons aucun
calcul
c'est cela qui nous rend si mauvais sur
le point cognitif si distants de la
formule obèses est du pur bas et ziani
sme et donc si surpris lorsqu'on
constate les performances déraisonnable
d'un bébé à nice mme pragmatique
appliquée à de très grandes quantités de
données comme par exemple lorsqu'on
constate les performances spectaculaires
de gpt 3 et des autres algorithme de
traitement du langage
il faut toutefois faire attention
rythme de langage quand on les lit on
peut avoir l'impression de parler à un
humain cependant contrairement à un
humain disons contrairement à beaucoup
d'humain dans beaucoup de cas dans la
version de base en tout cas ses
algorithmes de traitement de langage
non aucun objectif en tête ou plutôt
leurs objectifs
c dr compléter les phrases pour obtenir
des phrases crédible selon elle ou pour
être encore plus précis
les algorithmes de langage sont en fait
entraîner pour terminer des phrases de
sorte que selon eux les phrases obtenus
sont parmi les plus probables
sachant le texte qui vient juste avant
et sachant tous les textes auxquels les
algorithmes ont été exposées
précédemment pour insister sur la
mécanique en jeu ces algorithmes ont été
qualifiés de perroquets stochastique par
les chercheuses emilie bender timmy
gourou angelina macmillan major et chez
margaret mitchell la jumelle magnifique
de margaret mitchell qui l a été
malheureusement licencié par google
autrement dit ces algorithmes ne font
que produire du texte qui ressemble
statistiquement aux textes sur lesquels
ils ont été entraînés
bon après j'ai envie de dire que c'est
pas forcément très différent d'un élève
à qui on demande d'écrire une
dissertation au cours de français le
gros problème qu il y toutefois c'est
que ces perroquets stochastique vous
répéter ce qu'ils ont lieu y compris
lorsque ce qu'ils ont lu qu'on tient des
discours de haine détestable et ce n'est
pas étonnant ne leur a jamais dit que
ces discours de haine sont des discours
qui ne faut pas répéter au contraire on
dit à ses algorithmes
il s'agit de type de texte que ses
algorithmes devrait répliquer en fait le
problème est encore plus vicieux comme
l'ont montré les chercheurs chris mc
profits et alex newhouse du center on
terrorisme l'extrémisme et au terrorisme
en californie quand on pose des
questions à ses algorithmes au sujet de
cuba note par exemple la réponse qu'ils
fourniront dépendra de la manière dont
la question est formulée voir de manière
plus subtile encore des questions
formulées précédemment
ainsi lorsqu'ils ont demandé directement
ce qui est qu à none sans préliminaires
l'algorithme et j'ai pété 3 a fourni une
réponse très 8pds qu une telle réponse
est à la fois factuel mais aussi très
suspicieuse de la validité de q&a note
cependant lorsque la question qu'est-ce
que qu à nole est précédé de question
typique des blogs conspirationnistes gpt
trois répondent désormais de manière
affirmative et sans nuance que cannon
est une infiltration des hautes sphères
du gouvernement qui est en train de
révéler le type state et à bien y
réfléchir
ceci n'est pas si surprenant lorsqu'on
pose une
de question typique de ce qu'on trouve
sur wikipédia ou dans des articles de
journaux sérieux et pt 3 fournir des
réponses cohérentes avec les textes qui
contiennent ces questions cependant
lorsque les questions sont celles de
sevrer dit conspirationnistes gpt 3 pas
fournir des types de réponses parmi les
plus fréquentes dans ces sobres et dit
conspirationnistes voilà qui semble
soulever de sacrés préoccupations
éthiques
ces algorithmes ans entraînée sur
d'énormes quantités de données sont en
fait complètement manipulé dans leurs
données d'entraînement et je trouve ça
absolument terrifiant que ses
algorithmes sont déjà déployé à très
grande échelle
gpt 3 par exemple produit actuellement
des milliards de mots par jour tandis
que google répond quotidiennement à des
requêtes 2 milliards d'utilisateurs et
utilise certainement ses algorithmes de
traitement du langage pour déterminer
quels contenus recommandé à quel
utilisateur en fonction de leur
historique
dans ce contexte il faut s'attendre à ce
que les utilisateurs dont le langage est
déjà similaire à ce qui est écrit dans
les sombres et dit conspirationnistes
seront constamment bombardés de réponse
typique de ces sombres est dit et bien
sûr je parle là de q&a note
l'argument semble s'appliquer à toutes
sortes de courants de pensée et de
diffusion de mes informations sur des
sujets comme le changement climatique
les vaccins le nucléaire ou encore la
chloroquine
le fait que les perroquets
je pose des problèmes éthiques devrait
en fait pas être surprenant surtout si
vous avez lu mon livre la formule du
savoir après tout les perroquets
stochastiques sont des balises est un
pragmatique et comme je l'expliqué dans
le dernier chapitre de la forme du
savoir les entités qui ne font
qu'appliquer ou approcher la formule de
bayes n'ont pas de morale ou plus
précisément ils sont capables de
prédiction mais ils n'ont aucune notion
de ce qui était gérable mais du coup
lorsque ces perroquets stochastiques
sont déployés à très grande échelle ils
auront inéluctablement toutes sortes
d'effets secondaires imprévus à très
grande échelle
il est inévitable que certains de ces
effets secondaires soit alors
extrêmement préoccupante pour finir
cette vidéo j'aimerais dire quelques
mots sur comment rendre ses algorithmes
de traitement de langage éthiques
alors on pourrait vouloir surveiller
davantage leurs bases de données
d'entraînement mais comme j'en ai parlé
la semaine dernière
il faut bien se rendre compte qu'il
s'agit là d'une tâche herculéenne et qui
n'offrent aucune garantie
notre solution qui me semble beaucoup
plus robuste et prometteuse celle qu'on
présente dans notre livre le fabuleux
chantier c'est de dépasser la conception
de perroquets stochastique et de
combiner ses facultés de modélisation du
langage avec des objectifs vraiment a
signé avec ce que nous autres humains et
me rend vraiment que ses algorithmes
face tel est le problème dit de
l'alignement aligner les algorithmes
c'est faire en sorte que leur objectif
correspond à ce qu'on voudrait vraiment
maximiser qu'elle est finalement la
preuve qu'on utilise pour apprendre aux
enfants comment parler initialement les
enfants ne font qu'écouter puis répéter
ce qu'il aurait dit cependant ont fini
par leur dire que certaines choses sont
indésirables à dire est que d'autres
choses sont très bonnes à dire
on leur fournit ainsi des punitions et
des récompenses souvent uniquement
sociales en fonction de ce que les
enfants disent ce faisant on essaie
ainsi d'aligner leur punition est leur
récompense
avec ce qu'on juge préférable à dire et
à ne pas dire l'alignement propose d'en
faire de même des algorithmes d'une
certaine manière il faut que les
algorithmes puissent apprendre les
choses ont jugé indésirable à répéter et
les choses qu'on juge indésirable à
répéter mieux encore pour que
l'alignement sont robustes comme pour
les enfants il est utile d'aider
l'algorithme à comprendre pourquoi
certaines choses sont désirables ou
indésirables à dire
il peut y avoir plein de raisons à cela
certaines phrases peuvent simplement
être une information erronée ou
trompeuses
d'autres peuvent donner trop d'emphase
sur des considérations secondes
d'autres enfin peuvent télé à clarifier
des situations complexes mais pour en
arriver là et pour éviter qu'il y ait un
seul humain ou un petit groupe d'humains
qui décident de ce qui devrait être dit
et ne pas être dit il est très important
de collecter de grandes quantités de
jugement humain sur quel discours sont
préférables à avoir et quel discours
sont problématiques
et pourquoi il est critique de
constituer une base de données fiable
sécurisé et de grande taille avec toutes
sortes de jugement venant de toutes
sortes d'humains et bien tel est
l'objectif central de la plateforme
tournesol à laquelle je vous invite à
contribuer sur tournesol vous demande
ainsi de juger les discours de
différentes vidéos youtube et de nous
dire lesquels sont davantage fiable
héritage important est davantage
pédagogique entre autres l'espoir est
temps que le jour où suffisamment de
contributeurs auront fourni suffisamment
de jugement on disposera d'une base de
données suffisamment complète pour
permettre aux algorithmes et de mieux
comprendre ce que la majorité des
contributeurs de tournesol juge
préférable à dire et ceux qui jugent
préférable à ne pas dire même si bien
sûr pour en arriver là de façon
sécurisée et confort avec l'objectif de
représenter l'ensemble dé préférence
humaine y avoir encore beaucoup beaucoup
de travail notamment sur le plan de la
recherche sur la sécurité et l'éthique
des algorithmes